how's it going my name is Breanna teapot
and welcome to sergeants simulator 2013
selector became your control with AV ER
and space that's muscle overhand right
mouse to lower rotate hand they should
be pretty [ __ ] interesting perform a
heart transplant whoa look at my hat hey
what's going on hey hey what's your name
oh let me just touch it
oh don't worry Rubert you're in good
hands
you're in good hands rivet hmm smell my
hand smell a true badge
Jesus smell I fink everybody my hand
it's a [ __ ] helicopter what about
that
alright the surgery Charlotte began let
me cover your ugly face Trebek Stacey
wrangling a big out actually I can't
have this there we go perfect get to out
of my space I'm at sick come aside
you're not a [ __ ] [ __ ] there we go
alright that out of the way now let's
pick which of these tools
I know exactly no not all right let's
see it's so [ __ ] hard to grab stuff
seriously get away glass tube I don't
need you I want this off and I shall
have it all right Robert this might hurt
a little bit
don't worry about it that's a little
wood you gotta get rid of the ribs
oh yes that's it's just his lungs they
won't need them very long anyway oh wait
we're doing a heart transplant I forgot
all right how's that that's pretty oh
shut chat chat yes
the lungs I'll put you over here alright
don't do anything stupid lung now watch
it look what are you going look what did
I tell you long god damn it lungs you
can never trust them son of a [ __ ]
stupid ribs get out of my way doing
serious surgery here
[ __ ] hell mad gah ah well it looks
like we'll have to use brutal force on
your roommate it would seem that you
would not cooperate
oh that we got perfect perfect perfect
there we go
I didn't do this real bad you dead bah
dah
oh shut shut it wasn't me swear to God
let's give this another go all right
here we are perform the trust land shut
up that's pretty good now we might
actually get to the heart yes all right
he lost a lot of blood we must be
cautious from this point he's bleeding
he's gonna bleed to death doctor pants
don't wild Miranda kids knows exactly
what he's doing
yes out of the lugs there you are my
little friend machetes gonna play doctor
shut up dr. pants you're crazy
I know exactly what I'm doing yes yes
the scalpel scalpel scalpel this [ __ ]
scalpel it very much man must be very
cautious at this moment because the
heart is quite a [ __ ] he's not gonna
need he's got a blade dr. catch get the
gift a heart transplant oh god yes
get the heart get down odds dr. Pitt I'm
trying
get down dr. Pratt yeah yes what put it
in that nail that badge all robot you're
gonna live smell my fingers rub it Oh
what surgery Feld was going so well it
was going really well
all right breath that's a high five for
this game it's free if you wanna check
it out
I'll leave a link in the description
lack of everything enjoyed subscribe
comrade a and I'll see you next episode
however I may never burst LM every
moments bare with you is a moment I
treasure
ah